but even then you don't look at it like
this [__]
and even with that money i wasn't i was
i never had gotten arrested couple fist
fights stuff like that
but then
came senior year in high school and
that's when i started running with these
[__] gorillas
and we stole everything that wasn't
locked down i'm not proud to say these
stories
i mean from refunds we go to sears and
take out two stereos and bring them back
and get the cash back
you know if they mailed you a check
you're like [__] we got to go shoplift
some more
because a lot of places are the [__]
toys r us oh
i used to destroy toys r us
[Applause]
they give you that [__] jeffrey money
that's just as good as cash on the
street
i get fifty percent of the dollar of
that [__]
guys gotta [__] think man and it's
funny because
i never got arrested no police contact
and uh it was the redskins played the
raiders
in 83. i think the redskins won or
something
for the raiders one it doesn't [__]
matter i don't remember
but i won like i think i had the over or
something
that sunday night the guy paid me the
money so the next day it was january
it's [__] freezing in new york
[__] freezing and i decided to go
over and get some chocolate thai weed
[__] real good jamaican weed [__]
you that [__] would grow out of your
head like bob marley aren't you
and you had to go to like uh 178 there
was a couple spots i go to 150 something
that day it's three in the afternoon
i go into the health food stores they
call them you walk in they got three
sodas
and like an old newspaper that's it and
i got a bulletproof glass
and you tell the guy what do you want he
gives you like a 20 and and i told him a
quarter he gives me the chocolate thai
weed it's freezing out so i go do you
mind
if i roll the joint he goes now go right
ahead so i roll a joint in the corner
it's [__] freezing out there so i
walk out into into st
nick and i'm walking and i go into a
corner you know you can't let a joint in
the [__]
in the wind i go like this guys
and as i go to light it i get a gun put
to my head
and he's like don't move put the joint
down we've been watching you and within
that
a bunch of cop cars start coming out
like what the [__] what the [__] what
the [__] i didn't do nothing i was just
smoking a joint the guy's like put your
hands behind your head
and they're like there's a school up the
corner and somebody's been selling loose
joints to the kids
if you got more than like three dollars
on you we're gonna light you on [__]
fire
but in singles and they went in my
pocket i had eight hundred dollars and
hundred dollar bills
and i go dog i didn't sell no drugs i
live in jersey and then it was a [__]
mailman
he was an undercover cop dressed as a
[__] mailman you know how stupid i
[__] felt
i'm turning around he's got his little
mail carrier bag with the mason [__]
i'm like what the [__] so i was a
gentleman
and at the time i never carried id but
this was like a special van at the time
that they had like a machine
and you put your finger in and he asked
me what my name was i told him your
address i told him he goes come over
put your finger in this i want to get a
real identity this is a [__] 30 years
ago
and within like 20 minutes i had to wait
there handcuffed and a thing came up
and he goes you didn't you didn't lie to
me he goes you have the amount of weeds
you have i could arrest you
but he goes you have under seven grams
and i go and he took the weed and he
threw it
and he rolled it back up and he put it
in my pocket he goes i'm gonna give you
a ticket for the weed
answer the ticket and [__] it that's it
you'll never
have problems again i went and i got six
months probation in new york city
and then like a week later i have a job
with a friend of mine
and i find a checkbook
seriously i go to he had like a
construction job and we go and we find
the checkbook
and this idiot had a younger brother i
don't know what to do with this
checkbook and he goes give it to my
brother
and he'll give you some money back
[__] two days later i got the cops
looking for me and [__]
and those were my only two arrests
really i mean i never got in trouble
you know and i went down i don't know
what my [__] bail was
they let me out and i wanted to still
steal
but i wasn't sure i really wanted to get
my life together
so i moved to colorado